all right exclusively on CBS this  morning we've got a way to make  everybody feel better and it involves  Bob Marley Hey we are giving you a sneak  peek at a new music video from Bob  Marley take a look  [Music]  [Music]  emancipate yourself from mental slavery  people that yes the video premieres on  YouTube today it's being released in  honor of Bob Marley's 75th birthday  which would have been tomorrow I love it  I love it everybody heard of the music  video on YouTube 2747 drawings that's  right about the song that line in Mensa  paid yourself for mental slavery none  but ourselves can free our minds that a  to this union is strong  thanks glad